Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, Nummer 190 ist das schon und es ist die vierte oder vielleicht sogar fünfte Ausgabe unserer Liga Tour. Ich weiß das so genau gar nicht. Ist aber eigentlich auch gar nicht so wichtig. Wichtig ist, was in den europäischen Top-League passiert ist und das klären wir jetzt. Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir sprechen heute über drei der Top-League. Ich habe im Intro unterschlagen. Premier League haben wir heute nicht mit dabei, aber wenn sich keiner unserer Premier League Vertreter die Zeit nehmen kann für die Ligatur, dann reden wir umso ausführlicher über die wahren wichtigen Ligen in diesem Land und auf diesem Kontinent. Damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Ich freue mich sehr, dass drei Gäste hierher gefunden haben. Zum einen mit seinem Rasenfunk-Debüt. Ich habe mich so sehr darauf gefreut, dass jetzt endlich hier zu hören ist Marius Soyke. Ihr kennt ihn von transfermarkt.de. Ihr kennt ihn natürlich von Serie Amore. Das gibt dann auch schon einen Hinweis darauf, wo so sein inhaltlicher Schwerpunkt liegt. Aber ja nicht nur. Hallo Marius, schön, dass du mal endlich mit dabei bist.
Ich freue mich auch, dass es endlich geklappt hat.
Das sind wir alle. Denn heute wird es mal ein bisschen anders als sonst. Deshalb bin ich auch sehr gespannt auf die beiden Gäste. Fabian Pakulat, der Ed Rosengartler, auf Twitter. Hallo Fabian. Und David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 93, der Ed Ngungongvn, auf Twitter. Ich wollte komplett alles umschmeißen. Ich habe gesagt, Leute, heute machen wir es anders als sonst. Und dann war das Wehklagen groß. Mein Gott, was war das für ein Gejamme. Aber jetzt habe ich doch so ein schönes Plädoyer vorbereitet. Schalte es dreifach mir entgegen. Deswegen, okay, bei einem Plädoyer bleibt es. David, du darfst loslegen. Warum ist die Liga so besonders interessant? Was ist alles passiert in den letzten Wochen?
Wir müssen mit Ligue 1 reden, weil in Frankreich eine Mannschaft, die auf Defensive setzt, gerade in jedem Spieler ein Tor schießt. Weil ein super Team auf dem Spielfeld leidet. Weil ein Mittelklasse-Team sich mit Bayern und Dortmund vergleicht. Und weil in einem vierten Team ein Spieler vergleiche mit Modric angedichtet bekommt.
Ja, okay, ich sehe, warum du unbedingt die Pläne hier mit in der Sendung haben wolltest. Fabian, was war in La Liga so los?
Ja, wir müssen natürlich über La Liga sprechen. Warum? Weil wir wahrscheinlich am 16. Spieltag schon einen Meisterfest stehen haben. Wohl ich mich da vielleicht ein bisschen weit aus dem Fensterlinie. Weil David Alaba der neue Sergio Ramos ist. Weil Spieler wie Toni Kroos oder Marc Bartra ihren dicksten Frühling erleben. Weil ein Malagenio, also einer, der hier aus Malaga stammt, und gerade Betis auf den dritten Platz geballert hat. Und weil Rio natürlich nach wie vor die positive Überraschung des Saisons. Und leider im negativen Hinblick auch ein bisschen über Atletico Madrid sprechen, die so ein bisschen in der Krise stecken und unter den Erwartungen zurückbleiben. Neben Barca natürlich, aber da wissen wir ja schon länger, dass es nicht so läuft.
Okay, auch nicht so schlecht. Hört sich ehrlich gesagt anders. Könnten wir allein darüber eine Stunde sprechen. Da bin ich gespannt, was jetzt Malius einfach noch drauflegen möchte.
Wir sollten auf jeden Fall über die Serie A meinetwegen auch gerne zuerst sprechen, denn ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitbekommen habt, aber es gibt gerade den größten Fußballskandal in Italien, Salt Calciopoli 2006 und zusätzlich aber auch positive Nachrichten aus dem Sportlichen. Der Kampf um die Meisterschaft ist wahnsinnig spannend. Vier Mannschaften, die da innerhalb von vier Punkten liegen. Und Inter, das drauf und dran ist, vielleicht der Favoritenrolle am meisten gerecht zu werden.
Okay, allein deswegen hasse ich die Play-Doyers, weil ich dann Lust auf alle liegen habe. Aber vielleicht ist es ja gar nicht so schlecht. Ich würde sagen, also der Grund, warum ich keine Play-Doyers mehr wollte, war, ich möchte alles wild durcheinander mischen. Deswegen picke ich mir jetzt einfach Themen raus, so frei bin ich jetzt. Und damit wir dann das frische, sportliche Fleisch danach uns aufsparen, würde ich sagen, beginnen wir mit dem größten Skandal seit dem Calciopoli. Das interessiert mich nämlich wirklich. Marius, das wird dich jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig überraschen, denn da habe ich dich schon drauf angesprochen vor einigen Tagen. Daraufhin, das war ein ganz guter Teaser, das muss ich zugeben. Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder los in der Serie A und im italienischen Fußball?
Herr Bösezungen würde behaupten, es ist mal wieder bei Juve was los, was allerdings nicht 100%ig nicht ganz stimmt. Denn das, was im italienischen Fußball gerade passiert, das betrifft auch ein paar andere Mannschaften. Samptoria, Genoa, Atalanta, Roma und Napoli zum Beispiel. Allerdings ist natürlich die mediale Berichterstattung bei Juve immer am größten, immer am heißesten. Und tatsächlich hat es da, glaube ich, die meisten Ausnahme, Ausmaße da angenommen. Juve wird, oder unter anderem Juve wird von der italienischen Finanzbehörde und vom Verband untersucht, weil es dort in den letzten Jahren, ja wie soll ich das sagen, interessante Spielertransfers gegeben hat. David kann da sicherlich auch was zum Wechsel von Pjanic zu Barca und Arthur im Gegenzug zu Juve erzählen. Wenn man diese Transfersum, die da teilweise bei Tausspielern, auch für ganz, ganz junge Spieler, die per Weib noch keine Profi-Spiele absolviert haben, sich anguckt, dann ist einem das schon immer irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig vorgekommen. Und jetzt ist auch die Justiz dahinter gekommen, dass da vielleicht nicht 100%ig was stimmt und es vielleicht so gemacht wurde, um selbst überhaupt liquide zu bleiben. Und wenn das bewiesen werden sollte, dann so hofft die zuständige Behörde, könnte Juve vielleicht sogar mal wieder Zwangsabsteigen.
Das ist doch eine besondere Hoffnung. Ich versuche es mal kurz so zu erklären, wie ich mir das angelesen hatte. Und dann darfst du sehr gerne korrigieren. Und dann darf auch gerne Fabian mit reingrätschen, was zum Beispiel eben diesen Barcelona-Transfer damit angeht. Also es ist ja so, wenn man einen Transfer verbucht, also ein Spieler geht und ein Spieler kommt. Es geht um solche Geschäfte und der Spieler, der kommt, den schreibe ich mit dem Wert seiner Ablesesumme, kann ich den abschreiben über die Vertragslaufzeit. Das heißt, die Ausgaben, der Aufwand wird gestückt über mehrere Jahre und aber das, was ich bekomme für den Spieler, den ich gegeben habe, ist ja direkt in der Bilanz verbucht. Also jetzt habe ich es doch ein bisschen kompliziert erklärt. Ich probiere es nochmal. Spieler A wechselt, sagen wir einfach mal zu Barca, weiß nicht, wie ich auf den Vergleich komme. Und für den bekomme ich 40 Millionen Euro und behaupte einfach, der ist 40 Millionen Euro wert, weil Barca sagt ja auch, wir zahlen das und Spieler B kommt dafür zu mir. Und der kostet ebenfalls 40 Millionen Euro. Und das kann ich aber dann abschreiben über mehrere Jahre. Das heißt, für dieses eine Jahr kurzfristig habe ich eben eine höhere Einnahme, als die Ausgabe ist. Habe ich das so halbwegs richtig wiedergegeben?
Also besser hätte ich es nicht erklären können.
Na gut, das zeichnet Max aus.
Na gut, er hat ja auch nur ungefähr zwei Minuten dafür gebraucht. Das klingt für mich so, Fabian, das wird ja dann auch in Spanien ein Thema gewesen sein, oder?
Also noch habe ich noch nicht wirklich viel darüber mitbekommen. Es ist natürlich schon so. Ja, ich bin sehr sportlich fixiert gewesen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Und bei Barcelona ist ja die finanzielle Situation sowieso dermaßen durcheinander und ein Gewüst, Gewusst mit über 1,4 Milliarden Schulden. Da weißt du ja gar nicht, wo du anfangen sollst und wo du aufhören sollst. Also von daher muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, da kann ich euch nichts Bestimmtes dazu erzählen, außer dass natürlich einige Transfers hier auch passiert sind, die natürlich schon kurios waren. Vor allen Dingen auch jetzt die Wechsel vielleicht von Grießmann zurück zur Atletico Madrid, Luis Suarez von Barcelona zurück zur Atletico Madrid. Das war aber so ein bisschen auch in der in der Geschichte, dass eben Barca Geld sparen muss, vor allen Dingen gehaltmäßig. Die haben sie natürlich viel billiger verkauft, als sie sie damals eingekauft haben. Und diese Art-Tour-Geschichte war auch ein bisschen kurios. Der hat ja, glaube ich, ein halbes Jahr, war der nur in Barca oder wenn vielleicht auch ein Jahr und ist dann ziemlich schnell dazu Juve, dann mit diesem Pianiststil. Also es war schon sehr bizarr, aber so hinter die Kulissen diese Mühe habe ich mir nicht gemacht, dass ich da das alles so ein bisschen recherchiere. Und daher ist mir das alles zu undurchsichtig und hat mich eher auf Sportliche konzentriert.
Das sagt ja auch einiges aus, ehrlich gesagt, wenn das in Italien ein so großes Thema ist und dann aber beteiligte Vereine in der Premier League hatten wir ja, wenn ich es mir richtig nachgelesen habe und gemerkt habe, auch einige Beteiligte. Finde ich jetzt interessant, Marius, dass das in Italien so einen großen Wirbel erzeugt. Was ist denn da dann eigentlich der Vorwurf? Der Vorwurf ist Bilanzaufhübschung, weil man sich quasi einfach gegenseitig darauf verständigt. Beide Vereine müssen das ja tun, dass man einfach Spieler, die sagen wir einfach mal 10 Millionen wert wären am Markt, dass man die einfach für 70 Millionen tauscht und dann fließt zwar trotzdem Geld, aber man hat das eben künstlich hochgerechnet, weil man dann eben diesen positiven Bilanzierungseffekt hätte. Ist das dann auch der juristische Vorwurf?
Wahrscheinlich sehr viel klausulierter ausgedrückt schon. Es ist eine Übersetzung, die ich gelesen habe, war es geht um Ausstellungen von Rechnungen für nicht existierende Transaktionen. Tatsächlich, da kommen dann auch noch irgendwie die Honorare für Spielerberater mit rein, die ja auch da noch irgendwie mit aufgeführt werden sollen. Und ich glaube, warum das in Italien so ein sehr viel größeres Thema noch als in den anderen Ländern ist, dass es einfach viel gängiger Praxis ist. Also in Italien gibt es ja irgendwie auf dem Transfermarkt immer eine Sonderidee, die die Vereine da haben. Also früher war das mal diese Teilhabe von Spielern, wo man sich 50 Prozent der Spielerrechte geteilt hat und nach jeder Saison entschieden wurde, wo der Spieler denn jetzt eigentlich bleibt. Das wurde dann irgendwie abgestafft. Dann hat man quasi diese Leihen mit Kaufpflicht, was ja mittlerweile alle Vereine auf der Welt machen, erfunden. Und jetzt sind es halt irgendwie diese Tausch-Transfers mit den tatsächlich völlig überhöhten Ablösen. Und man muss sich das mal reinziehen. Die Summe dieser Kapitalerträge, die durch diese Transfers erzielt wurden, war höher als die Werbeeinnahmen, die die Serie A im gleichen Geschäftsjahr gehabt haben. Während in allen anderen Ländern sind die Werbeverträge viel größer als in Italien. Dadurch versucht man, sich konkurrenzfähig zu halten. Aber es ist natürlich ein sehr kurzfristiges Wirtschaften und kann auf Dauer so nicht funktionieren. Ich glaube, deswegen will der Verband da jetzt auch mal was machen.
Was ist denn da jetzt zu erwarten? Wird das die Liga bis Ende der Saison begleiten? Oder ist da zu erwarten, dass da jetzt relativ schnell irgendwelche Entscheidungen, Verhaftungen, keine Ahnung, was auch immer passieren?
Also bei Juve gab es auf jeden Fall schon zwei Ratzchen. Da sind unter anderem auch die Büros von Pavel Netved, dem Vizepräsidenten und Andrea Anjeli, dem Klubschef, der ja auch sowieso nicht das beste Jahr hatte, wenn man an Super League und so denkt, durchgeführt worden. Befragungen stattgefunden haben auch mit den ehemaligen Finanzchefs. Auch der Fabio Paratici, der jetzt bei Tottenham mittlerweile Sportdirektor ist, ist da irgendwie im Blick der Behörden. Und angeblich wird erwartet, also das stand in der Gazette de la Sport zum Beispiel, dass es sehr kurzfristig, also noch in diesem Jahr, ein erstes Ergebnis geben kann. Aber gut, ab die Mühlen der Justiz dann so schnell malen, wollen wir dann mal sehen.
Ich finde es insofern interessant, weil, also es ist völlig richtig, dass du darauf hingewiesen hast, es geht nicht nur um Juve, aber über Juve wurde berichtet, weil es eben um die Aberkennung der Meisterschaften im Raum steht und weil es dann, glaube ich, auch die meisten Leute interessiert außerhalb Italiens. Aber es ist wirklich ein italienisches Modell gewesen. Also ich habe mir das noch mal rausgesucht, jetzt allein die Wechsel im Jahr 2021, 2022, also in dieser Saison. Habe ich jetzt alles von transfermarkt.de, einfach nur die Zahlen. Die Zahl der Zugänge in der Serie A sind 963 Spieler. Zum Vergleich, die Premier League hat 293 Spieler. Die Abgänge sind 683 Spieler. 683. Und jetzt sortiere ich das Ganze einfach mal nach der Zahl der Zugänge und wer liegt da auf Platz zwei hinter der Serie A? Die Serie B mit 619 Spielern und 580 Abgängen. Das spricht natürlich auch dafür, dass da auch innerhalb Italiens das gemacht wurde. Das hast du auch schon angesprochen, diese Leih- und Kaufgeschäfte, die es da gibt. Aber wir sprechen da halt wirklich von ganz ganz anderen Zahlen, als wir sie zum Beispiel in der Bundesliga haben. Für die Bundesliga ist in diesem Zeitraum, wir sprechen nur von dieser einen Saison, sind es auch knapp 300 Spieler, die gekommen sind und 250 sind gegangen. Also es ist auch ein Wust, ein undurchsichtiger Wust, der da auf dem Transfermarkt passiert.
Hast du die Zahlen von Spanien auch? Das würde mich jetzt interessieren, weil das hier wie gesagt noch gar nicht groß kommuniziert wird irgendwie.
Also es ist für den selben Zeitraum 309 Zugänge, 280 Abgänge. Also das ist quasi das, wo sich alle alle Ligen bewegen. Die Liga hat auch 330 und 310. Also sprich, man kann sagen, jede der hier besprochenen Ligen hat eigentlich so rund 300 Zugänge und 300 Abgänge mit Auschlägen, leichten Auschlägen nach oben und die Serie A hat halt 960 und 680.
Ich hätte jetzt in Frankreich sogar weniger gewartet, weil wir ja so Geldprobleme hatten Anfang der Saison. Aber gut, dann wird wohl doch eine ganze Menge auch einfach vielleicht auch ohne größere Beträge gegangen sein.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall interessant.
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass diese Zahl der Transfers jetzt nicht nur an diesem Problem, sag ich mal, liegt. Das hat dann auch noch andere Gründe, wie es es gibt, weil es auf Juve überhaupt keine zweiten Mannschaften gibt. Die Spieler, die aus der U19 kommen, werden dann häufig, statt irgendwie ablösefrei mit einem 3-Jahres-Vertrag zu einem Zweitligisten, weil der das vielleicht über 3 Jahre gar nicht gestemmt bekommt, immer erstmal nur ausgeliehen. Deswegen hat Atalanta zum Beispiel 60 Leihspieler gerade oder so.
Ja, stimmt. Das kommt natürlich auf jeden Fall noch mit dazu. Also für die letzten 5 Jahre sind es insgesamt 4000 Zugänge. Aber gut, aber du hast völlig recht, das ist natürlich eine Einschränkung, die muss man noch machen. Ja, das ist ein ordentlicher Skandal, der aber anscheinend nur in Italien eine Rolle spielt. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob da noch was kommt. Denn wie gesagt, für diese Geschäfte, zumindest wenn sie außerhalb, also über Ländergrenzen hinweg gehen, über Ligengrenzen hinweg, braucht es noch jemanden zweiten, der sagt, ja, wir machen das jetzt einfach so, dass wir den einen Spieler mit 60 Millionen bewerten, den anderen mit 40 Millionen, weil wir hatten sowieso nur vor, 20 Millionen für den anderen zu zahlen. Also ich bin gespannt, ob das noch in den anderen Ligen ankommt. In der Liga A hat es ja anscheinend auch noch keine Rolle gespielt, David. Gut, naja, also das ist der größte Skandal seit dem Kalscho-Polli. Ich habe irgendwie so ein bisschen das Gefühl, das wird uns noch ein wenig begleiten. David, welche Skandale hatten wir in der Liga A? Auch wenn du sehr sportlich reingegangen bist, irgendein Skandal gab es doch auch.
Ja, ich kann natürlich nochmal über die Ausschreitungen sprechen. Eigentlich wollte ich das ja nicht, weil du ja mal dich beschwert hast, dass ich ständig so viel Politik da reinmische und so was. Und du doch viel lieber über den schönen Fußballsport reden kannst. Aber ich kann zumindest kurz nochmal erwähnen, das sollten einige Hörer ja mitbekommen haben, dass es schon wieder einen Flaschenangriff auf Pochett gab, diesmal beim Spiel gegen Lyon. Das Spiel auch früh abgebrochen worden ist. Und das reiht sich eben ein, eine ganze Liste von Vorfällen, wo eben unter anderem Dinge geflogen sind auf Spieler, wo aber teilweise eben auch Fans dann die Plätze gestürmt haben. Also die Liga hat definitiv Probleme mit Ausschreitungen. Einer der spannenden Aspekte, worüber es jetzt diskutiert wurde, in letzter Zeit, jetzt mal abgesehen von diesem, ja, Corona strengt unsere Nerven alle an und die Leute sind gereizt, etc. Was man ja nicht so wirklich beweisen kann, war der Hinweis, dass durch den Spielabbruch vergangenes Jahr in der Liga und auch durch die langen Geisterspielerinnen anschließend ganz, ganz viele Ordner den Job gewechselt haben. Weil sie logischerweise in den Arbeitslust waren und sich was Neues gesucht haben und eben auch nicht zurückgekommen sind. Und das heißt, dass viele Vereine gerade mit Ordnern arbeiten, die kurz eingearbeitet sind, dass sowieso Ordner nicht besonders gut bezahlt werden. Und du verständlicherweise vielleicht auch gar nicht so Lust hast, dich im Zweifelsfall dann für ein mageres Gehalt in die Menge zu werfen oder irgendwie mit Fans auszutauschen. Das scheint bei einigen Vereinen, die dezidiert sagen, wir haben unsere Ordner gehalten und die haben ein Draht vielleicht auch zu den Fans, weil die kennen sich vielleicht auch irgendwie oder so. Das sind immer dieselben. Da behaupten einige, das geht bei ihnen ein bisschen besser. Also das könnte zumindest ein Aspekt sein, der das so ein bisschen erklärt.
Aber glaubst du, dass das jetzt jenseits von diesen vielen Einzelfällen mal zu größeren, liegalübergreifenden Konsequenzen führen würde? Konsequenzen führen könnte, weil das ist ja durchaus, ohne es jetzt zu dramatisieren, aber es kann ja nicht sein, dass Spieler, in dem Fall jetzt auch ein Spieler, so häufig Ziel von Wurf geschossen ist.
Ja, äh, ja, ich glaube, die Liga hat da gerade ein ganz großes, die weiß nicht so ganz genau, wo sie hin soll. Und das liegt auch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen in der Historie. Es gab ja in der Frühphase der Liga, gab es ja Zeiten, da waren bestimmte Gruppen an Fans so richtig mächtig. Ich erinnere da an die Sachen, dass zum Beispiel Fans in Marseille, die Ultras in Marseille, die Karten sogar verkauft haben. Dann gab es eine Zeit, wo die Liga richtig hart durchgegriffen hat und das alles aufgesprengt, alles aufgelöst hat. Teilweise auch überdrastisch. Es gab ja bis vor kurzem auch noch haufenweise Verbote für Fans, auswärts zu reisen. Das ist ja auch was, was ich jetzt so aus anderen Ligen nicht kenne. Dass das Franzosen einfach verboten wurde, zum Beispiel zu reisen, ähnliche Dinge. Und eigentlich war die Liga gerade in den vergangenen Monaten wieder deutlich stärker auf einem Kurs, da ein bisschen mehr Dialog auch reinzubringen. Versuchend auch einen Mittelweg zu finden. Weil ich glaube, einfach nur mit harten Sanktionen kommst du da auch nicht klar. Also insofern wird das ganz spannend sein, was sie jetzt tun werden. Klar, du kannst das noch nicht komplett vom Kontext lösen. Da ist natürlich aktuell auch einfach viel Gereiztheit und unpolitische Aufruhr in Frankreich generell.
Das Video vom gestürmten Weihnachtsmarkt wird vielleicht so mancher gesehen haben in den sozialen Netzwerken. Ich traue mich gar nicht zu fragen, Fabian, hast du auch einen Skandal für mich? Oder bist du jetzt der Erste, der sagt, nein, bei uns ist alles sauber, La Liga ist sauber?
Also sauber, sauber sind wir in Spanien natürlich auch nicht. Aber das einzigste Skandälchen, was ich jetzt mal außerhalb des Sportes an sich nennen könnte, wäre halt, dass Realpräsident Florentino Perez weiter auf die Super League pocht und dieses Ziel nach wie vor verfolgt. Und er für ihn, dass die einzigste Rettung des Fußballs allgemein ist und so weiter und so fort. Ansonsten gab es bei uns tatsächlich nur sportliche Geschichten, rund um die Liga zu erzählen. Und Spanien ist allgemein relativ entspannt auch in dieser ganzen Corona-Situation. Die Leute gehen relativ gut mit der Sache um. Eigentlich schon seit Beginn. Und ja, das hat sich eigentlich so durchgezogen jetzt bisher.
Hab ich heute gelesen, ihr habt eine großartige Impfquote. Und alle sind total happy und voll dahinter.
Man hört dich so sehr aus deiner Stimme, David.
Es ist in Spanien tatsächlich so ein bisschen historisch auch begründet. Spanien hatte ja die längste Diktatur in Europa bis 1975. Die Spanier sind schon noch so ein bisschen autoritärhörig. Wenn man denen sagt, das ist jetzt so, dann wird das nicht so hinterfragt wie zum Beispiel in Deutschland, wo ja gerne mal alles 15-mal hinterfragt wird. Und dementsprechend gab es da gar keinen großen Aufschwung, sage ich jetzt mal, was irgendwelche Querdenker anbelangt.
Das ist jetzt die negative Interpretation. Ich hatte was gelesen, die Spanier sind sozial und gesellschaftlicher.
Sind sie auch, absolut. Also wenn es harte Fahrt kommt, hält man hier schon toll zusammen. Aber schon dieses Nicht-dagegen-Arbeiten, das ist schon auch, glaube ich, historisch ein bisschen in den Köpfen verankert.
Nicht Gegenarbeit, da sind wir doch irgendwo im Pressing. Jetzt müssen wir irgendwie mal zu uns Sportlichen fahren.
Oder beim schon feststehenden Meister. Ich gönne es auch Fabian wirklich von Herzen. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, Fabian, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es dein erster internationaler Kurzpass war, den wir gemacht haben damals noch alleine. Den haben wir ja aufgenommen, als gerade bei euch die Ausgehzeit für Kinder genutzt wurde. Also im krassen Lockdown. Viel, viel härter als alles, was wir hier in Deutschland erlebt haben. Deswegen gönne ich dir persönlich das sehr von Herzen, dass es bei dir jetzt besser ist. Und wir sind ja selber dafür, für unser Schlamassel hier verantwortlich. Aber jetzt wollen wir über den Meister sprechen, der schon fest steht. Mit welcher Mannschaft kannst du uns da denn überraschen?
Also es ist nicht die Riesenüberraschung, aber Jungs und Mädels und Damen und Herren, ich muss es euch leider ganz ehrlich sagen, ich gehe fest davon aus, dass Real Madrid wieder Meister wird in Spanien. Das haben die letzten zwei, drei Spieltage leider deutlich belegt, oder was heißt leider? Sie haben es auf jeden Fall belegt, wie man auch immer das sehen möchte, denn sie sind am konstantesten und leider sind so alle Teams, die danach sind, und ich denke da vor allen Dingen an Atletico Madrid, die vielleicht sogar den stärksten Kader haben in der Offensive, seit ich zumindest Atletico Madrid kenne. Die kriegen es nicht hin, konstante Leistungen abzurufen. Haben wir am Wochenende jetzt verloren zu Hause gegen Mallorca, das ist ein Aufsteiger, das ist einfach dann halt zu wenig. Und Real Madrid ist jetzt davon gezogen. Ich glaube, acht Punkte sind sie vorne, wobei noch das ein oder andere Spiel aussteht für die Verfolger. Aber die einzige Mannschaft, die im Moment wirklich vorne konstant zeigt, das ist Real Madrid und da wird sich, glaube ich, nicht viel machen lassen diese Saison.
Ich dachte ja so ein bisschen vor der Saison, als sie Ancelotti zurückgeholt haben, dass der das nicht mehr drin hat. Ist es denn so, dass er nur die Erfolge oder das Grundwerk, das Zidane da gelegt hat, irgendwie verwaltet? Oder hat er da auch seine eigene Duftmarke hinterlassen?
Da bin ich schon bei dir, David. Ich bin auch kein Ancelotti-Verfechter, dass ich sagen würde, das ist der Taktik-Fuchs schlechthin. Das ist der Trainer im Moment, der irgendwie die schlauesten Ideen hat. Aber er hat einfach ein Team, das funktioniert. Du hast schon recht, da ist diese Mittelfeld-Achse von Zinedine Zidane, die spielt er nach wie vor mit einem, das habe ich vorher schon kurz angesprochen, wieder genesenen Toni Kroos. Der hatte eine fette Schambeinentzündung, hat sich operieren lassen und spielt seitdem wieder wie ein, na ja, junger Gott, das ist jetzt vielleicht zu viel gesagt, aber spielt richtig starken Fußball. Hat mit Modric einen, den er natürlich kennt, wie seine Westentasche so ungefähr. Und Casimiro macht zwar ein bisschen keinen so guten Eindruck, aber dann haben sie ja noch diesen Kammerwinger, der dann immer wieder reinkommen kann. Vorne haben sie mit Karim Benzema, wisst ihr alle selber, brauchen wir gar nicht lang drüber sprechen. Und sie haben mit Vinicius dieses Jahr jemanden dazu bekommen, in Anführungszeichen dazu bekommen, der jetzt quasi den jungen Cristiano Ronaldo mimt. Der wirklich plötzlich Tore schießt, Tore vorbereitet, Spiele entscheidet alleine. Das, was man sich von ihm erhofft hat, bei seiner Verpflichtung vor zwei, drei Jahren, scheint jetzt tatsächlich einzutreffen. Dementsprechend ist gegen Real Madrid kein Kraut gewachsen im Moment. Und die Geschichte mit David Alaba finde ich auch sehr faszinierend. Der ist hier sofort reingekommen und macht hier den Sergio Ramos. Der ist absolut der Abwehrchef, dirigiert das Spiel auch von hinten raus. Und das ist wirklich sehr faszinierend, wie schnell der da reingewachsen ist und die Mannschaft quasi von hinten führt. Da kommt im Moment sonst keine Mannschaft dran an dieses Grundgerüst.
Ihr habt euch jetzt beide gegenseitig David genannt.
Also David bin ich.
Ich dachte noch, ob ich in die Shownotes einfach alle drei als David reinstechen würde.
Wie früher bei Freiburg einfach in Willien.
Zu David Alaba habe ich gelesen, die Pressestimme der größte Diebstahl des Jahrhunderts. Natürlich in der typischen Art und Weise in der unterkulten Berichterstattung, wie es halt so der Fall ist. Ich glaube, es war nach irgendeinem wichtigen Champions League Spiel. Aber das scheint ja schon ein sehr wichtiger Pfeiler zu sein. Wird denn das überhaupt noch thematisiert, dass mit Sergio Ramos ja der eigentliche... Also das Original ist ja weg. Und jetzt hat man halt offensichtlich nicht bei Wish bestellt, Sergio Ramos, sondern beim Original und einen sehr guten Ersatz bekommen. Aber wird es überhaupt noch thematisiert, dass es ja diesen krassen Umbruch gab?
Paris hat Ramos bei Wish bestellt. Der spielt ja auch.
Nein, es ist tatsächlich so, dass Sergio Ramos überhaupt nicht vermisst wird. Und das ist ja schon mal eine Ansage. Also wenn es über Sergio Ramos gesprochen wird, dann eben, dass er in Paris nicht spielt. Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar ein sehr kluger Schachzug von Real Madrid, ihn abzugeben und nicht zu verlängern. Also es geht eher in die Richtung. Und wie gesagt, dass man über Ramos eigentlich gar nicht spricht oder dass man ihn nicht vermisst, das spricht sehr viel. Da wird alle wahr.
Tja, und so haben wir jetzt Real eben als einzige Mannschaft, die in den letzten drei Spielen alles gewinnen konnte. Und zusammen mit Real Betis, über die wollen wir später auf jeden Fall noch sprechen, hast du ja auch schon angekündigt. Aber dann lass doch mal zu Paris springen, David, und zurück in die Ligue 1. Wie ist die Situation da? Und warum spielt Ramos nicht?
Ramos spielt nicht, weil er verletzt ist. Das ist, also, da ist eine ewig lange Leidensgeschichte und alle grübeln und wundern sich. Da kann ich aber tatsächlich auch nicht mehr dazu sagen, als das die Medien berichten. Paris ist insofern ganz spannend, weil, wenn du gerade gesagt hast, Madrid steht da oben und überzeugt, dann kann ich sagen, Paris steht da oben und überzeugt nicht. Haben elf Punkte Vorsprung, trotz nicht überzeugender Leistungen. Und zwar jetzt wirklich seit Wochen. Also, das eigentliche Case in Point war jetzt wieder am Wochenende, das Spiel gegen Lens. Da hat der geschätzte Alexis Menouche, der ja hier auch schon zu Gast war im Live-Kommentar, gesagt, also selten hat man PSG so Leidensehen in der Liga wie heute Abend gegen Lens. Und ein französischer Taktikexperte, dem ich auf Twitter erfolge, der hat geschrieben, also wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass bei so viel Geld im Kali die Taktik immer noch darin besteht, den Ball lang auf Mbappé zu schlagen. Und Pochettino wirkt nach wie vor überfordert. Der hat während des Spiels, ich glaube, drei oder viermal das System geändert. Der ist von 4-3-3 auf 4-2-3-1 gewechselt, hat Verratti nach rechts gezogen, ist dann wieder auf 4-3-3 zurück, hat Verratti nach vorne geschoben. Und die gesamte Mannschaft scheint irgendwie ideenlos. Nach der Pause sind sie dann irgendwie auf den 3-5-2, haben drei Spieler rein, und haben es dann doch wieder mit ihrem typischen Paris-Dusel-Glück halt noch auf dieses 1-1 geschafft, was echt ein Klinikbruch war für Lens, die großartig gespielt haben, zu dem ich gerne auch noch ein paar zwei, drei Sätze sagen kann. Aber bevor ich jetzt Barista verlasse, möchte ich zumindest noch einen Begriff in den Raum werfen, den ich neu gelernt habe in den letzten Wochen. Das ist die Tuchelisation.
Und das bedeutet?
Die Tuchelisation, so man es verstanden habe, ist der Begriff dafür, dass ein Trainer, der vermutlich mehr könnte als Heik, durch das Präsidium eines Vereins kleingehalten wird oder durch Mannschaftszwänge daran gehindert und marginalisiert wird. Und es wird gerade also debattiert, ob Pochettino schon bei PSG der Tuchelisation unterliegt oder ob er einfach nicht so gut ist, wie man glaubt.
Was ist denn an dem Gerücht, wann eigentlich mit Zidane eventuell Pochettinon erfolgt?
Na ja, also Zidane ist natürlich ein Nationalheiligtum in Frankreich. Und da Pochettinon halt nicht liefert gerade und das alles so trist ist, ist das, glaube ich, also erstmal ganz, ganz viel Wunschdenken. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob Zidane das offiziell negiert hat oder ob er einfach nur schweigt. Ich meine klar, vorstellbar wär's. Also sollten sie Pochettinon rausschmeißen. Ich bin sicher, dass Gespräche stattgefunden haben, sagen wir mal so. Also das ist ein, wie gesagt, ein Nationalheiligtum hier. Genau. Und ansonsten ganz kurz noch wenigstens ein paar Sätze zu L'Anse, die wirklich also ein überragendes Spiel gemacht haben. Ganz starker Start direkt, intensiv, starke Konter, hohes Pressing. Sie haben die Innenverteidigung von PSG unter Druck gesetzt, haben klug, Umschaltspiel gemacht, haben sich aber auch nach der Führung nicht zurückgezogen, haben ihre Konter weiter ausgespielt, hatten leider dann ein bisschen auch Pech oder mangelnde Präzision. Und dazu noch dieses fantastische Publikum da im Stadion Bolleher, das ja in Frankreich auch schon seit langem einen entsprechenden Ruf hat. Die haben zwei schnelle und technisch starke Außenstürmer, die haben zentral technisch starke Spieler mit Forfana und de Corre. Forfana ist auch wirklich klasse im Umschaltspiel, haben Schienenspieler mit Frankowski und Klaus, den wir auch noch kennen aus der Bundesliga. Und das ist eine Mannschaft, da müssen Dinge zusammengreifen, damit das funktioniert alles, damit die im Pressing auch erfolgreich sind. Aber dann können sie echt zaubern, das macht tatsächlich Spaß einfach zur Zeit.
Aber dreimal unentschieden in den letzten drei Spielen. 2 zu 2, 2 zu 2, 1 zu 1.
Ja, genau, das ist das, was ich sagte, damit da müssen Dinge zusammengreifen. Also wenn da vielleicht mal Konstellation nachlässt, dann wird das auch nicht immer ganz klappen. Das gilt im Übrigen für alle Mannschaften da oben. Und deswegen hat ja Paris auch diesen Vorsprung, den sie haben. Alle Mannschaften, die da stehen, haben irgendwelche Hänger gehabt. Vielleicht noch fast mit Ausnahme von Rennen, die einfach zu Beginn der Saison eine ganz, ganz schlechte Phase hatten. Und seitdem eigentlich eine ziemlich konstante Phase haben. Aber auch die haben jetzt zuletzt gegen Lille zum Schlüssel verloren.
Tja, es ist relativ eindeutig in Spanien, in Frankreich, wo es aber ganz, ganz eng ist, das hast du ja auch genauso angekündigt, Marius ist die Serie A. Da entmutet er sich schon völlig erschrocken. Was sind denn die Faktoren, die dazu führen, dass man dieses unglaublich spannende Rennen hat? Also Milan 38 Punkte, Inter 37 Punkte, Napoli 36 Punkte, Atalanta 34 Punkte. Das ist ja traumhaft.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Dass sich da jetzt nicht schon eine Mannschaft abgesetzt hat, das freut mich auch jede Woche immer wieder. Inter, wobei, das hatte ich ja irgendwie auch schon angekündigt, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Inter das als Ball tun wird, denn die haben sich jetzt nach der Findungsphase gefunden und haben einfach den mit Abstand breitesten Kader, der wohl auch in der Spitze sicherlich am besten besetzt ist, trotz der Abgänge von Lukaku und Hakimi. Und bei Napoli und Milan merkt man jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen, die haben ja beide jeweils irgendwie ihren besten Saisonstart der Vereinsgeschichte gehabt, jetzt aber auch jeweils schon mal verloren. Napoli ist sogar schon zweimal ausgerechnet auch in den Spitzenspielen eben gegen Atalanta und Inter. Dass sich da so ein bisschen die Verletzungsprobleme häufen und dadurch, dass das Spiel oder diese Form, die sie am Anfang hatten, diesen Lauf, den sie hatten, da so ein bisschen in Stocken gekommen ist, also gerade bei Napoli. Ich glaube, das hatte Mario ja auch im letzten Kurzpass quasi schon angekündigt, dass das womöglich irgendwann passieren könnte. Atalanta hat auch nach einer Schwächephase zu Saisonbeginn, jetzt haben sie, glaube ich, fünf- oder sechsmal hintereinander gewonnen oder noch häufiger vielleicht. Diese Offensivmaschine, die sie auch in den letzten Jahren gewesen sind, sind sie jetzt wieder und profitieren mittlerweile auch davon, dass sie nicht nur in der Spitze sehr gutes Personal haben, sondern auch in der Breite mittlerweile auf einen Fondus Kangasperini, da einen Spielern zurückgreifen, der wirklich beeindruckend ist. Deswegen könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass sie auf jeden Fall bis zum Ende oben, vielleicht nicht ganz ganz oben, aber dahinter Platz 2-3 mitspielen werden wieder.
Wenn ich mir die Tabelle angucke und schaue, wie kommt dieser enge Korridor zustande, dann sehe ich nach 16 Spielen bei Milan, Napoli und Atalanta zwei Niederlagen, bei Inter nur eine Niederlage. Halte ich da jetzt einfach mal die Bundesliga dagegen, dann sehe ich, es gibt genau eine Mannschaft, die es in 14 Spielen geschafft hat, nur zweimal zu verlieren, das ist der FC Bayern. Ansonsten haben wir nur Mannschaften mit mehr Niederlagen. Also Union, Freiburg und Leverkusen mit drei, Dortmund mit vier, Hoffenheim und dann viele andere mit fünf und sechs. Das heißt, das ist der große Unterschied, dass diese vier Mannschaften so selten verlieren. Kann man dafür jetzt auch irgendwelche größeren Gründe finden? Liegt das an der Stärke der restlichen Liga? Wird in der Serie A besser verteidigt oder anders auch Spiele vielleicht zu Ende gespielt? Oder ist es jetzt Zufall?
Zufall würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen. Man sieht es ja auch alleine am Punktestand. Atalanta hat jetzt schon sieben Punkte Vorsprung auf Juve als fünften. Die Champions League-Vereine sind da sozusagen unter sich. Grundsätzlich würde ich immer noch sagen, dass in der Serie A an einem guten Tag auch die Mannschaften aus den unteren Tabellenregionen gegen die Großen was holen können. Nur ist es so, dass vor allem Milan und Napoli wirklich sehr effizient und gut gespielt haben bisher und inter-eigentlich auf Sicht vielleicht das werden müsste, was der FC Bayern aktuell in der Bundesliga ist oder seit Eonen in der Bundesliga ist.
Und damit auch Juve ablösen kann? Also längerfristig jetzt?
Also ob sie jetzt auch neun Mal am Stück Meister werden, das vermag ich jetzt noch nicht zu beurteilen. Aber es liegt auf der Straße für Inter. Sie müssen es nur noch richtig managen, dann können sie jetzt über die nächsten vier, fünf Jahre sicherlich die bestimmende Mannschaft in Italien sein.
Krass, was hat sich denn da so verschoben?
Na ja, Juve ist schlecht eingefroren. Es ist ja so, dass das vorher gerade Milan auch jahrelang überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt hat. Sicherlich ist es so, dass die Roma und Lazio, das auch mal ein, zwei Jahre, ein, zwei stärkere Jahre jetzt wieder ein bisschen weiter unten sind. Und in diese Lücke, die Juve sich selbst irgendwie erarbeitet hat, sag ich mal, dadurch, dass sie jahrelang sicher abgewirtschaftet haben, ist Inter jetzt herausragend reingestoßen. Und tatsächlich ist es auch einfach so, dass trotz der großen finanziellen Zwänge des Sommers, wo man deswegen Konter zurückgetreten ist, deswegen Lukaku und Hakimi halt gegangen sind, dass man in Zagih eine sehr, sehr gut funktionierende und homogene Mannschaft dahingestellt hat. Auch einen, da blüht selbst ein Hakan Salonoglu absolut auf im Moment über den letzten fünf Spielen immer getroffen. Man sagt ja bei dem schon länger, dass der eigentlich auch nur in sehr gut funktionierenden Mannschaften selbst funktioniert.
Und Juve kann sich da nicht einfach rauskaufen. Das wäre ja die Lösung des FC Bayern.
Das ist ja im Grunde das, woran sie quasi gearbeitet haben, mit den eingangs besprochenen Transfergebaren. Es hat aber einfach nicht so gut funktioniert. Da gab es sicherlich auch im Scouting oder in der Kaderplanung ein paar nicht so schlaue Ideen, gerade was die Besetzung im Mittelfeld anbelangt. Und das Experiment mit Cristiano Ronaldo, jetzt geglückt, ist sportlich oder nicht, da kann man sicherlich darüber streiten. Aber es ist als eine Mannschaft, die vor fünf Jahren herausragend besetzt gewesen ist mit Pogba und Tevez und Pirlo natürlich und der Verteidigung mit Bonucci und Chiellini, trotz großen finanziellen Einsatzes hat man es nicht geschafft, das Level zu halten.
Tja, das kann dann doch auch noch passieren im modernen Fußball. Das ist ja interessant. Da stellt sich für mich ja die Übergangsfrage, Fabian. Also in der spanischen Liga haben wir jetzt schon festgestellt, okay, also Meisterschaft ist fix, aber da gibt es hier auch manche Mannschaft, die überrascht. Du hast Betis vorhin schon angesprochen, du hast von Spielern gesprochen, die den Xten-Frühling erleben. Das ist auch so ein bisschen so ein roter Faden, der sich durch die La-Liga-Segmente zieht. Wie sieht es denn hinter Madrid aus in der Tabelle?
Ja, da ist ein bisschen Abstand, aber dann kommen die zwei Clubs aus Sevilla, der FC Sevilla, auf zwei. Betis im Moment auf drei, wie gesagt, durch einen unwahrscheinlich starken Auftritt in den letzten Spielen von Juan Miguel. Juan Miguel heißt der gute Mann, ein junger Kerl. Na ja, so jung ist er eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Aber er schaut immer noch aus wie 18. Ne, den haben wir hier beim FC Malaga großgemacht. Der kam hier aus der eigenen Jugend, der hat unter Pellegrini damals gespielt beim FC Malaga, als wir noch das Scheichgeld hatten und in der Champions League und so weiter für Furore gesorgt haben und jetzt spielt er eben unter Manuel Pellegrini bei Betis Sevilla und er ist nicht der begnadetste Fußballer, aber er ist schneller und er hat vor allen Dingen einen unglaublichen Torinstinkt. Und ich glaube, 8 Treffer hat er im Moment jetzt in der ersten Liga, in den letzten zwei Spielen 4 Treffer erzielt. Bei Barcelona hat Betis am Wochenende gewonnen mit 0 zu 1. Treffer war von ihm. Also da läuft es richtig gut bei Betis. Und wie gesagt, sie haben halt auch wirklich einen sehr guten, erfahrenen Trainer. Und dementsprechend würde es mich nicht wundern, wenn sie zumindest unter den ersten 5 bleiben würden. Sevilla sowieso auch, denke ich, auch vom Kader her. Wie gesagt, das Einzige, was ich sehr bedauerlich finde, ist eigentlich, dass Atletico nicht konstanter spielt und real mehr kitzelt. Denn, wie gesagt, ich glaube, die haben eine Offensive, da schnallst du mit der Zunge. Das ist das Beste, was Atletico wahrscheinlich seit Jahren oder überhaupt hatte. Und da ist es mir einfach zu wenig. Vielleicht klappt das auch nicht dann mit dem Spielkonzept von Giorgio Simeone zusammen, aber wenn ihr euch einfach mal überlegt, ich habe da vorne Luis Suarez, Antoine Griezmann, Joao Felix, Yannick Carrasco, Angel Correa. Also ich habe hier fünf absolut direkte Stimme. Und dann verliere ich zuhause eins zu zwei gegen Mallorca. Ich glaube ganz ehrlich auch, Max, dass diese Doppelpleite gegen Liverpool in der Champions League, der hat ein bisschen geknackt am Selbstbewusstsein der Colchoneros. Die müssen ja heute Abend unbedingt was reisen in der Champions League. Sonst ist nämlich da auch Schicht im Schacht. Und ja, wie gesagt, also ich habe mir da sehr, sehr viel mehr erwartet von Athletico und bin ein bisschen enttäuscht. Ich glaube, die sind im Moment fünfter. Und ja, gut, sie haben ein Spiel weniger. Sie könnten auf sieben Punkte rankommen, auf Real Madrid. Aber trotzdem, das ist bisher zu wenig leider.
War das denn aus deiner Sicht geschickt, Grießmann zum Beispiel überhaupt zurückzuholen? Also hat das nötig getan?
Ja, ich meine, bei Athletico Madrid hat er wahrscheinlich so gut gespielt wie noch nie in seiner Karriere. Gut ganz am Anfang bei Real Sociedad San Sebastian, als er damals von Frankreich in die La Liga gekommen ist. Er war schon auch stark, aber das war ja noch ein anderes Level, sag ich mal. Aber was er bei Athletico Madrid gemacht hat, das ist eigentlich das, was ihn ja eigentlich so richtig stark gemacht hat. Und dann wechselst du zu Barcelona. Nicht ganz unpolemisch, wie ihr vielleicht mitbekommen habt. Und da hat er zwei Jahre oder drei Jahre eigentlich nicht oder fast nie das abrufen können, was er eigentlich oder für was er im Stande ist. Und von daher fand ich sportlich den Schritt zurück zur Atletico Madrid absolut nachvollziehbar für ihn, weil er einfach gedacht hat, hey, ich kann doch gut kicken, ich gehe jetzt wieder zur Atletico und dann zeige ich es den Leuten wieder, wie ich es einfach kann. Aber es funktioniert eben gerade im Moment nicht. Ob er jetzt zu viel Konkurrenz im Sturm hat oder ob, wie gesagt, taktisch da einiges nicht stimmt, ich weiß es nicht genau, aber schon schade. Also sportlich kann ich den Wechsel zurück absolut nachvollziehen, aber es hat nicht den Effekt gehabt, den er sich wahrscheinlich selbst erhofft hatte.
Wie viele Heimtore hat der Athletico da mit seinem Supersturm?
Statistik bin ich schwach.
Der Max hat das bestimmt jetzt direkt auf.
Ich fliege schon. Die Frage, die kann er reinschieben, und dann komme ich aus dem Off gleich.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, dass es ja auch immer ein bisschen was Romantisches hat, den einstigen Helden zurückzuholen. Ich wohne in Hamburg, und da hat das mit einigen großen Spielern auch schon nicht geklappt.
Also, 12 Heimtore hat Atletico. 12 zu 6.
Der Hintergrund meiner Frage ist ein Teil des Teasers, den ich noch auflösen wollte. Das Team, das sich mit Dortmund und Bayern vergleicht. Die französischen Medien haben jetzt vermehrt darauf hingewiesen, dass Straßburg aktuell nicht nur in der Liga, die zweitmeisten Tore hinter PSG geschossen hat, sondern auch die in den großen Top-5-Ligen die torreichste Heimtor-Mannschaft ist. Mit 23 Toren gleichauf, mit Bayern und Dortmund eben. Wobei das ein bisschen geflunkert ist, weil Frankreich schon 17 Spieltage hatte und die Bundesliga nur 14.
Das hat man nicht umgerechnet. Da gibt es ja auch nicht eine Möglichkeit des Runters zu rechnen.
Weil du immer wieder nach Teams to Watch fragst, wäre auf jeden Fall Straßburg. Die spielen einen wunderschönen Angriffsfußball gerade. Die haben einen ganz großartigen Ludovic Ayorg vorne im Sturm, der trotz seiner Größe von knapp zwei Metern technisch stark ist. Ich erinnere mich noch dran, der war vor ein paar Jahren schon da. Jetzt hat sich nichts Besonderes zum extremen, kompletten Stürmer gewandelt. Er kommt auch aus Réunion, im Indischen Ozean, so wie Pochett auch. Er hat eine Kalt-Schneidigkeit vom Tor, hat Instinkt für richtige Entscheidungen, hat ein extrem gutes Zusammenspiel mit Diallo, mit dem anderen Stürmer. Die haben drei Stürmer da vorne, Straßburg. Diallo, Gamero und Ayorg. Da passen immer nur zwei in die Aufstellung rein. Das heißt, Diallo ist sogar derjenige, der am seltensten in der Startelf steht. Aber die klicken alle zusammen. Du siehst, dass der Trainer Stefan, den ihr vielleicht kennen könntet, weil ich ihn mal vor, ich glaube, das war schon eine Weile her, im Kurzpass erwähnt hatte, als der Trainer, der Rennen so stark gemacht hat und auf einem Pokalsieg so verantwortlich ist. Stefan hat die Taktik auch von Straßburg nochmal richtig schön erweitert, lässt die Spieler gerade vorne enger zusammenstehen, vertikal zueinander positionieren, dass die Pässe besser ankommen. Ayork ist ein Stürmer-Typ, der sehr mannschaftsdienlich ist. Da klickt ganz, ganz viel zusammen. Das macht sehr, sehr viel Spaß. Und der Ausrufezeichen war jetzt gerade am Wochenende, das 13-0 gegen Nidzei, die ja eigentlich auch eine richtig, richtig starke Mannschaft sind gerade. Auch da haben wir jetzt mit dem Tor von Ayork. Und das Tolle ist, am kommenden Sonntag wird Straßburg sogar gezeigt, weil sie gegen Marseille spielen.
Haben wir hier noch einen Hinweis mitbekommen.
Am Sonntag ist eh ganz, ganz... Also man kann sich da eigentlich den ganzen Tag Frankreich anschauen. Am 15.00 Uhr spielt Rennen gegen Nidzei. Und Rennen auch eine überragende Mannschaft gerade. Ich hatte das gerade schon kurz erwähnt. Die hatten so ein bisschen gebrauchten Start, trotz ihrer 50 Millionen, die sie ausgegeben haben zum Transfer. Und dann hat aber der Trainer Ginesio umgestellt, hat Jonas Martin reingenommen und dann mit so einer Doppelspitze Thierry Laborde und in der Folge haben sie gegen Paris gewonnen. Sie haben Lyon verprügelt, was ziemlich brisant war, weil Ginesio kam von Lyon und der wurde da entlassen, weil man sich eigentlich so einen eher glamouröseren, international erfahrenen Trainer gewünscht hat, der Lyon halt bei den ganz Großen mitspielen lässt.
David, was heißt ausgerechnet auf Französisch?
Hahaha, äh, äh, äh, oh Gott, fällt mir jetzt so an. Nicht so einfach? Nee, nee, weil ich glaub, mit Kontext wieder, äh, äh, egal. Also, ne, genau, ja, also, äh, du siehst, worauf ich hinausfühle. Also, man sah es in Ginesio nicht, und wer ist jetzt bei Lyon? Äh, äh, äh, Peter Bosch, der, ähm, der, an dem mittlerweile auch die Journalisten langsam verzweifeln. Weil sie feststellen, dass er nicht von seinem Dogma abweichen will, aber die Stierichtiger Mannschaft hat. Spielt sein Stiefel runter und, ähm, und hat aber irgendwie nicht die Spieler dazu, das Pressing und das, was ihm da vorschwebt, durch entweder können oder wollen. Und, ähm, genau, ja. Und bei Rennes muss ich noch ganz kurz hinweisen auf, äh, auf einen, auf einen jungen Spieler, der jetzt durchgestartet ist, den ich auch eingangs erwähnt hatte, Lovro Maillère, oder Marge, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man ihn auf Kroatisch ausspricht, ich hab's vorhin so draus zu finden, ich kann keinen... Also die Franzosen sagen nur so weise, Maillère, Maillère. Ähm, ist ein, ein Kroaten mit einem unglaublich wunderbaren linken Fuß, und der offenbar Dinge im Spiel sieht, die andere nicht sehen. Äh, deswegen wird er auch schon offenbar, selbst in Kroatien mit Modric eben verglichen, auch wenn es sicherlich das aktuell noch zu früh ist. Aber der analysiert schnell, der, äh, das macht unglaublichen Spaß, den zuzusehen, und das wäre super, super toll, den sich entwickeln zu sehen in den nächsten Jahren. Ähnlich wie man ja schon Kammerwinger bei Rennen sich halt entwickeln sehen können. Und, äh, wohlgemerkt, die sind gut, obwohl sie Kammerwinger abgeben mussten an Madrid. Und, ähm, also auch da geht ganz, ganz viel zusammen gerade. Santa Maria kommt in Form, der von Freiburg dahin gewechselt ist. Ähm, ja, also auch die, auch die ein Team to watch, und auch die kann man sehen, am Wochenende gegen Netzer.
Ja, und am Supersonntag nicht vergessen, 21 Uhr Real Madrid, Atletico Madrid. Da, um wahrscheinlich einer der letzten Chancen der Colchoneras dann nochmal ranzukommen, also bitte abschließen dann mit der Liga. Wer das in Deutschland überträgt, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber, Anja.
Und PSG Monaco auch noch.
In der Serie A kann ich um 12.30 leider nur mit Torino gegen Bologna dienen.
Also ich werde hier irgendwann das TV-Tipp-Segment glaube ich noch einführen müssen. Ich wollte noch kurz sagen, wenn die Hörerinnen und Hörer mal lachen wollen oder vielleicht auch andere Emotionen zeigen, einfach mal alle Mannschaften zuhalten in der Ligue 1-Tabelle und dann auf die Ergebnisse der letzten sechs Spiele gucken und dann raten, welches Team ist das von Peter Bosz? Und ja, es ist das, dass in den letzten sechs Spielen verloren gewonnen, verloren gewonnen, verloren unentschieden gespielt hat. Platz zwölf.
Jaja, also jetzt auch gegen Bordeaux. Er hat dann plötzlich versucht, die Dreierkette auszupacken und ist auch damit grandios gescheitert. Ganz ehrlich, mit dem Kader ist das auch irgendwie so ein bisschen fragwürdig. Da sind Spieler wie Aoua drin, Gimaresh, Paketa. Paketa ist super sauer, dass er von Bosz ständig als falsche Neuen aufgestellt wird. Darum mohrt es auch sehr gerade.
Ich will ja auch nicht grundsätzlich über Peter Bosz lästern. Das kam jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu hämisch rüber. Aber die Spielideen nicht anpassen, ob das die Spieler, die man zur Verfügung hat, das ist das, womit er mehrfach in Deutschland auch gescheitert ist. Das kann man, glaube ich, schon so sagen. Also mit Sokrates einfach die Abwehrreihe bis an die Mittellinie vorschieben.
Ja, das gehört nur. Er wurde ja auch von den Medien gefeiert, auch zurecht. Das ist ja schön, wenn du einen Trainer hast, der ein Konzept hat. Das zeichnet aktuell die Liga und durchaus aus, dass da eine ganze Reihe an Trainer reingekommen sind, die durchaus attraktiv spielen lassen wollen. Nur ist es halt auffällig, dass man mit seinem Ballbesitzer und dem konstanten Pressing, du brauchst halt die Spieler dafür. Und bei Lance klappt es eben, und bei Straßburg klappt es auch, so wie sie es machen. Und bei Lyon klappt es eben sehr offenkundig gerade nicht. Und dann bleibt dem am Ende nicht viel übrig.
Dann würde ich die Frage noch gerne als Abschlussfrage an die anderen beiden weitergeben. Bei Marius fangen wir mal an, denn da haben wir irgendwie auch, finde ich, also der Serie A haben wir sehr, sehr interessante Trainer. Wenn wir jetzt gerade über Peter Boss gesprochen haben, wer ist denn gerade der umstrittenste oder vielleicht auch der genialste Trainer der Serie A deiner Meinung nach? Wen sollten die Hörerinnen und Hörer kennen?
Also der genialste Trainer, da kommt für mich eigentlich nur Gian Piero Gasperini von Atalanta in Frage, der aus dem Nichts ein Team entwickelt hat, das teilweise mit den auf jeden Fall den aufregendsten, vielleicht nicht immer den schönsten, aber sicherlich den aufregendsten Fußball in der Serie A spielt. Aber den haben natürlich auch viele Leute schon mitbekommen. Ansonsten sicherlich Vincenzo Italiano von der Fiorentina, der auch einen sehr straighten, aber technisch basierten Fußball spielen lässt. Und Igor Tudor bei Hellas, der aus quasi eine Kampfmaschine im guten alten Bundesliga-Pressing-Stil geformt hat. Aber so, dass es tatsächlich gut anzusehen ist. Vielleicht, weil die Einzelspieler besser sind, ich weiß es nicht. Die aber durch diese Kampfkraft, die sie einfach aufs Feld bringen, ein Element haben, das nicht viele andere Mannschaften in Italien haben. Darum stritten ist sicherlich Jose Mourinho.
Stimmt, an den habe ich gar nicht gedacht. Da war auch schon wieder etwas unter der Woche. Ich habe es nur an mir vorbeigelegt und nicht verstanden. Irgendetwas mit Gehalt oder so? Oder ist es etwas Sportliches oder ist es nur Boulevard? Dann können wir es auch weglassen. Deswegen hat es mich auch nur gestreift. Fabian, wen hast du dann noch zu nennen? Diego Simeone, der große Offensivspektakelmann.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sein Problem, dass er nicht weiß, wie er mit seiner Offensivkraft so umzugehen hat.
Wobei, Sie haben ja die drittmeisten Schüsse der Liga. Ich habe das vorhin nachgeguckt, weil ich genau diese Argumentation erfahren wollte. Ich dachte mir, die Statistiken geben es nicht so ganz her, dass Atletico so ultradefensiv spielen würde.
Ja, sie versuchen schon, um Gottes Willen. Es sind auch hinten definitiv viel anfälliger als in den vorher Jahren. Ein Oblak z.B., Torwart, der war ja jahrelang auf einer Augenhöhe, mit Manuel Neuer und so weiter und so fort, also ganz, ganz oben im Regal. Und der patzt dieses Jahr auch komischerweise ziemlich oft. Der macht so ein Alison-Bekker-Jahr wie letztes Jahr Liverpool, der sich dann auch plötzlich eine Auszeit für eine Saison genommen hat. Bei Oblak sieht es so ähnlich aus. Da gibt es noch ein paar Spieler, wie Philippe in der Innenverteidigung. Also es ist auch hinten nicht mehr so nett bei Atletico. Aber weil wir bei den Trainern waren und den interessanten Trainern in der Liga, müssen wir natürlich wieder zur Reihe Valle Cano gehen, zu Andoni Iraola. Über den werden wir noch einiges hören in den nächsten Jahren. Keine Frage. Interessant ist auch die Entwicklung vom FC Valencia, wie ich finde, und der Bordolas, auch ein sehr engagierter Trainer, der eigentlich immer auch so hart an der Grenze seine Mannschaften spielen lässt. Valencia ist jetzt immerhin auf Platz 8 vorgerückt. Und Marcelino finde ich persönlich ein sehr interessanter Trainer bei Athletic Bilbao dieses Jahr. Die haben erst drei Niederlagen, leider auch sehr viele unentschieden. Deswegen konnten sie sich noch nicht weiter nach vorne arbeiten. Aber das geht vom Spielermaterial eh ziemlich schwierig. Athletic Bilbao wissen ja vielleicht viele, da spielen nur Basken und dementsprechend kannst du dir da keinen Brasilian nach vorne hinstellen. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessanter Trainer. Und diese drei würde ich auf jeden Fall nennen. Die sind sehr, sehr interessant und werden mit Sicherheit noch den einen oder anderen größeren Club übernehmen irgendwann.
Ja, da können wir gespannt drauf sein. Weil das Stichwort gerade gefallen ist, eine kurze Frage noch. Ich habe gehört, dass Valencia jetzt von der Stadt dazu aufgefordert wurde, sein Stadion, an dem man ja seit 2009, glaube ich, baut und das quasi als unvollendete Bauruine die Stadt ziert, jetzt relativ bald einen Finanzierungsplan vorzulegen, das zu vervollständigen. Hat das jetzt eine Bewandtnis, dass das bei mir aufgeschlagen ist? Also hat das eine andere Qualität als in den vergangenen Jahren, wo ja sowas durchaus schon auch mal passiert ist?
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass in Valencia im Moment der Druck auf Peter Lim, auf den Eigentümer von Valencia, erhöht wird, dass er jetzt endlich mal, ja, sich mal wieder zeigen soll, sich bewegen soll, entweder investieren soll oder verkaufen soll. Da läuft es ja in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren ja auch schön den Berg runter. Da wird nicht mehr investiert, sondern Geld rausgeholt. Und dieses Stadion ist tatsächlich diese Baustelle, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Jahre die schon brach liegt. Vielleicht ist es ein Druckmittel der Stadt, ihn so mal wieder irgendwie nach Spanien zu locken. Könnte ich mir gut vorstellen. Aber es ist tatsächlich eine schwierige Situation für Valencia im Moment. Und es wäre nun mit Sicherheit sonst normalerweise ein Club, den wir uns die Top 4, Top 5 ansiedeln würden, die aber jetzt das Feld gerade so ein bisschen von hinten aufrollen müssen. Und wie gesagt, kann man mir gut vorstellen, dass es ein Druckmittel vielleicht auch sein soll für den Eigentümer.
Na gut, dann behalten wir das mal im Auge. Aller, allerletzte Frage jetzt und tatsächlich, hat irgendjemand von euch noch etwas auf dem Zettel, wo er sagt, wenn ich das jetzt nicht noch erzähle, dann ärgere ich mich die ganzen nächsten Wochen bis zur nächsten Ligatur. Marius, irgendwas noch?
Was vielleicht noch anschließt an den Erfolg von Inter. Sie haben jetzt auch im Derby gegen Milan zum ersten Mal in der Serie A Feminile gewonnen überhaupt.
David?
Ich sollte zumindest den allerersten Satz zu meinem Pitch noch aufdröseln. Die Mannschaft, die auf Defensive setzt und ein Tor schießt, das ist nämlich Brest, die sind gerade die Mannschaft der Stunde. Die haben sechs Siege in Folge erzielt und haben tatsächlich, obwohl sie das mit einem sehr, sehr minimalistischen Fußball und sehr tiefstehend und dem Ball den Gegner überlassen, hat man jetzt auch gesehen gegen Marseille. Da hatten sie, glaube ich, am Ende, ich glaube, 26 Prozent Ballbesitz. Aber haben trotzdem zwei Tore gemacht. Und haben tatsächlich, das ist total verrückt, haben in diesen 17 Spielen seit Saisonbeginn in jedem Spiel ein Tor geschossen. So, und das, ja, also Hut ab. Die haben einen ganz witzigen Trainertausch gemacht vor Beginn der Saison. Die haben ihren Trainer Dalolio zum Montpellier geschickt und haben dafür gleichzeitig der Saccarin aus Montpellier bekommen. Ich weiß nicht, kann sich jemand an so was erinnern, was mal in der Liga passiert ist? Dass zwei Trainer direkt die Plätze getauscht haben?
Eintracht Frankfurt, FC Bayern, 1976 glaube ich, Jula Lorand zu den Bayern. Und na, kommt jetzt. Nee, nicht. Ach, jetzt sitze ich da drauf. Aber da ist das mal passiert, auch innerhalb von zwei Wochen tatsächlich. Da saß dann bei einem Spiel... Ach Gott, das ist leider alles weg. Da saß dann der Kapitän der Frankfurter, war quasi Spielertrainer für das Spiel in München. Und gleichzeitig saß Lorand auf der Tribüne, weil er Frankfurt versprochen hatte, dass er das Rückspiel im UEFA Cup, das damals stattgefunden hat, nicht dann schon für die anderen coachen würde. Deswegen gab es quasi ein Spiel, wo beide Trainerbänke leer waren. Und damals bedeutet der leer auch noch leer.
Also Hut ab an Brest, weil die sind eigentlich eine sehr kleine Mannschaft. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich noch mal Gelegenheit bekomme, die noch mal in einem künftigen Liga-Show zu erwähnen.
Sehr gut. Und Fabian, hast du noch einen allerletzten Punkt?
Ja, vielleicht Barca weiterverfolgen. Nein, weil der Effekt Xavi sehr interessant war, finde ich. Also ich meine, kadermäßig reicht es dieses Jahr, das haben wir ja schon besprochen, nicht für die Top 4 wahrscheinlich oder zumindest nicht für die Top 3. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass unter Xavi jetzt wieder Feuer unter der Hütte ist, dass er versucht, viele junge Talente jetzt auch einzubauen und man sieht, dass dort wieder ein bisschen anders Fußball gelebt, Fußball gespielt wird, nicht immer erfolgreich, aber ich glaube, für die Katalan entwickelt sich jetzt schon langsam ein bisschen was. Es wird ein Übergangsjahr jetzt werden und ich finde es aber bisher ganz positiv, wie die Entwicklung ist, auch wenn die Ergebnisse jetzt nicht alle positiv waren, aber zumindest ziehen die Spieler wieder an einem Strang und das Ganze sieht wieder recht anständig aus, würde ich sagen.
Barca aktuell Tabellen, siebte mit 23 Punkten, 16 Punkte hinter Real, aber die haben wir ja sowieso schon als fixen Meister hier verkauft. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, das hat großen Spaß gemacht. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir wünschen uns alle Feedback auf diese andere Form der Ligatour. Dass es jetzt eine Liga weniger war, war tatsächlich Zufall. Das hatte nur mit Terminen zu tun, aber lasst uns gerne Feedback da, wie ihr diese Sendung fandet und folgt auch gerne allen Gästen auf Twitter. Zum einen David Frogier de Ponlevoy, der Add n'Gungung vn auf Twitter. Wie soll ich es aussprechen, David?
N'Gungon.
Das tut mir leid. Da sage ich lieber n'Gungong vn, das ist doch auch so schön. Das ist doch wie so ein Glockengeläut. Also danke dir, David, dass du mit dabei warst.
Danke dir, Max, für die Einladung.
Dann haben wir den Add Rosengartler, Fabian Pakulat. Danke dir, Fabian, für deine Zeit. Und Marius Soyke, der Add M Soyke. Das ist mal ein Twitter-Handle, sage ich euch, liebe Leute.
Danke dir, Marius, dass du mit dabei warst. Wahnsinnig kreativ, oder ja, vielen Dank, dass ich dabei sein konnte.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepaywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure Unterstützung. Wie ihr das tun könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de und unterstützt damit nicht nur diesen Podcast, sondern auch alle Gäste, die beteiligt sind, die ein kleines Honorar von euren Spenden bekommen. Herzlichen Dank für alle, die das getan haben. Ansonsten hören wir uns wieder im Rasenfunk. Irgendeine Sendung gibt es immer, die ihr hören könnt. Macht's gut, bleibt gesund, bis bald.